hello my name is mathias and i am
the founder of datatec in this video
i would like to show you how you
can easily get your data descriptive online
but first of all what
are descriptive statistics under the
term descriptive statistics are
statistical methods for
describing data using  Statistical characteristic values
Diagrams Graphics or tables
summarized there are, for example, the
location measures with the mean
value median model value or the sum or the
control measures such as the
standard deviation, the variance and the
range or many different
tables, the best known are the
frequency tables and the cross table
and  of course lots of graphics for
the bar chart the pie chart
or the line chart it is very
important that you
can only
describe your sample with the de ski and statistics i.e. the data that
we have
you cannot make any statements about the totality
j  But now I've talked enough now
I'll show you how you can evaluate your data online descriptively I
also offer date up de for this and look at the
statistics calculator
you can copy your own data into these upper tables for
this simply
click on table teachers and make sure
that  the variable name is in the first row
i just use the example data
we want to evaluate our data descriptively
so click on the
trip down and now we can
click on the variables down here that ewe
want to evaluate let's
start with the bearing dimensions and the
control dimensions  if you just
click on income now we can
choose which dimensions we
would like to have displayed, for example the
mean value the standard deviation the
minimum and the maximum then
we get the table below with the exact values ​​of
course we can now also
click on the old one then  age is
simply added to this table  below
you will still get diagrams
suggested in this case, for
example, litter diagram where we
apply the income and the old
one, you can of course also click in the
original variables and nominal war,
for example, you click on the
place with the characteristics as in
Berlin and Zurich  you get a
frequency table here you can now
also click that you also want to have
the percentage and the valid percentage
, so you now get a
frequent table with the frequencies
with the percentage and the valid percentage in
addition you get
diagrams suggested like you
you can process the data graphically, for example
in a bar chart or in a
pie chart, if you now click on a
second nominal or original variable
, e.g. gender, you get
a cross table this is the
variable at the top here the variable
gender is entered and you can see how
often the jew  Urgent combination occurs in your
data of course if you
want you can also simply change the axes
and here below you will find
suitable graphics again you can simply
browse through them and see if one of the
graphics fits of course you can send in
many other combinations
you can do this for example
click on gender and a metric variable
then you get a subdivision
between male and female and
you get the mean value for the
income the standard deviation for the
income the minimum and the maximum
exactly which values ​​you clicked above
you can of
course also output the frequencies again
therefore, depending on what you
click on, you are already
suggested suitable results if you want to
create graphics separately, you can
also click on the agave up here.
here you can now create a box plot,
e.g. if you get clicks on income and
gender for two big
lots e  once for male and once for
female or you can simply have both
diagrams output is the
gram scatter diagrams or the blend
altmann place
either you are on diagrams and can have
the whole diagrams output
or you are on the statistics calculator
and all the location dimensions frequency
collect and output crosstabs do
you want to know more about
crosstabs or the frequency of the band
just watch my next videos
and otherwise i would say
just try the tab it's
easy goodbye and see you next time